نحن الان في ميناء اسكندرون هذا الميناء
الذي كان محور للاحداث في الايام الاولى
من الزلزال كما تشاهدين دمار كبير في هذا
الميناء عشرات الحاويات التي دمرت باضافه
طبعا الى الحاويات او مئات الحاويات التي
تضررت نتيجه الحرائق التي اشتعلت في
الايام الاولى لهذا الزلزال طبعا ميناء
اسكندرون كما ذكرت كان محور الاحداث خلال
الايام الاولى بسبب الحرائق التي لم تتوقف
خلال اول ثلاثه ايام من الزلزال وبالتالي
كان هناك جهود كبيره من السلطات في محاوله
اطفاء الحرائق كما تشاهدون ما تبقى من هذه
الحاويات هنا في هذا الميناء قد
اصبحت اثرا بعد عين اضافه الى دمار حاويات
اخرى لم يصلها لم تصلها الحرائق عفوا
لكنها دمرت بشكل كبير اذا دمار كبير في
بناء اسكندرون لكن السلطات يعني قبل قليل
عندما كنا نجول قرب هذا الميناء شاهدنا
عشرات الاليات التي تحاول ابعاد هذا
الركام لتسهيل حركه او التسهيل عوده
الحياه الطبيعيه والعمل في هذا الميناء
الى ما كان عليه قبل الزلزال كما ذكرت
راويه بالعوده الى موضوع رفع الانقاض لا
شك ان الاعمال البحث والانقاذ قد انتهت
بشكل تقريبا شبه كامل في عشر ولايات
منكوبه حاليا الجهود تتركز على توفير
مساكن مؤقته كنا يوم امس في ولايه غازي
عنتاب تحديدا في مدينه اصلاحيه نستطيع
القول ان اعمال تجهيز المساكن مسبقه الصنع
والكرفانات قد وصلت الى ما نسبته تقريبا
40% في محاوله وسباق مع الزمن لتجهيز هذه
المساكن هناك في اصلاحيه في غازي عنتاب في
اقرب وقت بالاضافه كما ذكرتم حركه النزوح
مست من هذه الولايات الى ولايه اكثر امنا
مع اطلاق الحكومه التركيه قبل يومين
برنامج بيتك بيتي في محاوله
توفير ايضا مساكن اضافيه حيث تشمل هذه
المبادره تقديم اصحاب كل من يملك منزلين
هذا الشخص الذي يملك منزلين بامكانه
التبرع اما بشكل مجاني
لعائله من الجنوب الولايات المنكوبه او
الحصول على اجار رمزي تتكفل الحكومه
التركيه بدفعه وبضمانه الحكومه التركيه
بالنسبه لاسطنبول نعم اعمال الكشف او
تقريبا اعمال او فرق البحث
والكشف على المباني
تقوم بعملها بيانات رسميه اكدت ان نسبه او
الطلبات التقدم من المواطنين للكشف عن على
المباني ارتفعت بما نسبته تقريبا 90% بعد
حدوث الزلزال هذه الطلبات تقدم الى
البلديات المحليه هناك في اسطنبول وتقوم
فرق من البلديه بمراجعه الطلب ومن ثم
ارسال فريق الى المبنى للتاكد من سلامته
وموافقته للشروط
الزلازل اذا كما تابعنا يعني حاله من
جهود كبيره من الحكومه التركيه لتوفير
مساكن مؤقته ومحاول بدء بعمليه رفع
الانقاض استعدادا لبدء عمليات اعاده
الاعمار
زيدان يعني باختصار لو سمحت الصوره التي
نشاهدها هي طبعا لميناء اسكندرون حيث
الزلزال شاهدنا العديد من الفيديوهات
الاحتراق هذه الحاويات ولكن سؤالي لك يعني
هل العمل في هذا الميناء متوقف بشكل كامل
وهل من موعد تقريبي لعودته او استئنافه
للعمل ان كان بشكل كلي او جزئي
نعم يعني من خلال ما شاهدناه لا هناك حركه
جزئيه في المينايه نحن وصلنا الى هذه
المنطقه قبل حوالي ساعه رصدنا هناك بعض
الاليات التي تعمل لكن هذه المنطقه التي
نتواجد فيها الان العمل فيها متوقف بشكل
كامل لكن في بقيه مواقع الميناء نعم هناك
حركه ايضا هناك موانئ قريبه يعني اسكندرون
لا تعتمد فقط على هذا الميناء هناك موانئ
قريبه تبعد حوالي 15 كيلو مترا الى سبعه
عشر كيلو مترا العمل فيها جار على قدم
وساق وهناك ايضا سفينه رست قبل ايام وفيها
سفينه لايواء لمتضررين الزلزال فيها شقق
فندقيه او غرف فندقيه لايواء عشرات
العائلات المتضرره من الزلزال